hi guys it's me quinn and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really notices
me so i did my talk on
why there are no robots in dune and that
went over pretty well and i just wanted
to give beginners to the series some
context as to why certain things in the
series are the way they are
now i want to do a video about the
politics of the dune series so for those
of you that have seen the movie but
haven't read the books but are
interested in learning more about like
what the heck is going on so to begin
explaining the politics of the dune
universe we have to first talk about the
landsrad now the lands rat is mentioned
several times in the movie the lands
ride is essentially the collection of
great houses within the imperium so if
you've seen game of thrones lannisters
starks baratheons house tully if they
existed in the dune universe they would
be members of the great houses of the
lands rat so these are wealthy families
which are given the fiefdom
over certain planets house atreides for
a very long time was given the fiep them
over the planet calidan
now the lands rat is resided over by the
emperor shadom carino iv
at the start of the dune series house
carino has ruled over the landsrad for
many many generations
many if not all of the great houses in
the lands rat including the imperial
house share shares in chome company now
think as chum company as kind of space
amazon they essentially have a monopoly
on the commerce of the universe anything
that needs to be bought and sold it's
handled through chome and this is also
where the guild comes in now we see very
little of the guild in the movie though
there is mention of them the guild have
a monopoly on space travel without the
guild you cannot travel anywhere in the
universe and it's based on the fact that
their navigators use a kind of secret
hidden method to mutate themselves with
spies
along with the holtzman engines which
fold space to basically navigate across
the universe and no one else knows how
to do it without computers and computers
are banned so the guild has a monopoly
on space travel and they work as
partners to chong
so if chome is the delivery company
amazon then
think of the guild as fedex or the
postal service
but also think of them as like every
airline
because they handle all of the traveling
in the universe now the great houses of
the lands rat all wield varying amounts
of power house carino the imperial house
is obviously very very wealthy because
they are the imperial house but they
also train very efficient very skilled
fighters known as the sardi car on their
prison planet solution secundus and this
basically keeps everyone in check no one
wants to face the wrath of the star to
car
now even though the emperor does have
wealth and does have strength he is
jealous of the rising power of house
atreides it's just the philosophy of
house atreides that breeds loyalty and
they're becoming more popular in the
lands rat and there's rumors that
atreides soldiers rival even the
emperor's sardocar there's also a feud
that's been going on between
specifically house of treaties and house
harkonnen that's been happening for
several generations
now underneath the front-facing politics
of the imperium the emperor the landsrad
chome company the guild the rivalries
between the great houses there is the
bini jesuit sisterhood now though the
many desert sisterhood only claims to
live to serve they are the secret rulers
of the imperium and they do so just by
operating from the shadows and they have
very manipulative techniques essentially
they operate under the guise of a
religious organization but they use this
in order to infiltrate worlds
governments and all sorts of systems so
that they can manipulate the people to
their own ends and they sometimes do
this hundreds of years in advance just
in case as was the case with a racket
the vinnie jesuit have also been
secretly crossing bloodlines for
generations essentially the great houses
of the lands rat exist as a pool of
genes for the benny jesuit to pick from
whenever they need many of the
characters we see in the series
including jessica the baron potentially
even duke latel himself are products of
the bini jesuit breeding program
the world arachus also called the planet
dune is at the center of all of this
because it is the only place where the
spice melange is produced now spice is a
mysterious psychoactive chemical that's
found in the deep desert that extends
life it heightens awareness and in
certain special individuals it can open
prescient site so you can think of spice
as a metaphor for oil but just add on
the fact that it's also a substance that
makes you live up to twice as long and
heightens your awareness and there is
the added fact that spice is so
addictive that once you become addicted
you can't stop taking it otherwise you
will die
so not only is spice essential to
commerce and traveling in the universe
there's also countless rich people
throughout the imperium that are
addicted to spice and without it they
would die that said you can understand
the significance of why arrakis is at
the center of imperial politics and why
it is so essential to the imperium that
arrakis remain a desert and that the
ecological transformation not go through
you can kind of think of dune as a
complicated drawn out chess game between
the emperor the mini jesuit the lanzerad
the guild and chong company i hope this
helps explain the politics of dune a
little bit better thanks guys for
listening peace out
you